oh did you see yeah did you see the
Kanye one where he was like yeah they
were like Kanye storms off field and
yells at soccer mom and then you watch
it they were just like kind of maybe he
was like nah and then walked away yeah
man no I'll tell you what happened there
oh yeah I'll tell you what I don't know
what happened but it didn't look like it
was a big deal okay no if any when uh so
you know my son plays on the opposite
soccer team yeah and uh my girl texture
was like oh uh Kanye's here he's late
and then she was like he's arguing this
mom but the mom was like she's the one
who initiated it right because he was
just trying to root on his son she's
like will you pipe down that's when he's
like what no and then he went to go he
hasn't seen his son in a little bit so
he went to go hug his son and then uh
the security who was there was somebody
else stop them from seeing his son and
that's what set him off he was like hold
up that's my son why did they do that I
don't know I don't know I'll tell you
but then uh so Connie had to get going
so he literally ran on the field I mean
you know tears in his eyes yeah yeah and
would like give him a kiss and got ran
off and he they may come out to be this
horrible person no everyone's another
they [ __ ] them man everyone was really
[ __ ] up yeah like that whole thing
like Kanye freaks out no no you can't
even freak out Kanye was upset he
couldn't touch his kid well you know
that should be you know from watching uh
the Kardashian show I mean because
Rachel you know what I mean she loves
that [ __ ] so I'm sitting in here in bed
looking and when they were showing him
in the first season you know but when
they show him in the first season I was
like oh this is like a completely
different dude like the dude that they
showed yeah and all this stuff is not
this guy like he's like very understated
and like you know he's with his kids and
he's like I don't want to be the cool
dad I'm the yeah I'm the dad that like
where's the silly stuff yeah my kids
want me to do that no he's a good dad
yes but what I'm saying is like it's
like a weird like you know but at the
same time it's like when like this this
goes back to even with this P Diddy
video
like I'm glad to say that that was
nothing but like you have to know you're
that famous and everybody's filming um
you know when you're that famous you
have a little bit of a responsibility
right but Kanye's things different his
son's playing a soccer game and he
didn't ask for that I'm not talking
about that I'm just saying in general
when you're that famous right and you do
something and it's going to get out then
you have to answer for that right I mean
Kanye like he legit went crazy in the
media
for like a month and then there was all
this backlash and now he's coming out
being like hey yeah sorry I shouldn't
have said that about George Floyd okay
uh probably I shouldn't uh I didn't mean
to come across like all the Jews are
terrible you know I mean like he really
realized oh there's there's consequences
oh I didn't hear him backtrack at all no
he did he apologized oh he did he
apologize a number of times but it
you know he's done this before where he
he does these things manic
or I don't I'm no doctor but whatever it
is I don't think it's that I think it's
calculated like even with this thing no
way bro well I listen I'm telling you I
mean the whole hold on it was a bad
calculator he didn't realize how much
backlashed hey he's done this he's done
this with black people white people he's
done it with heads of Studios before
because he's trying to move the needle
and get out of a situation so this he
even went on drink Champs and was like I
can say anti-smack stuff and they Adidas
still won't do [ __ ] knowing Adidas all
you want to do is get out of the deal's
contract that's all you want to do he
wanted to get out of Valencia contract
you want to get out of the Gap contract
so he did the most extreme thing he
didn't realize that when you start going
anti-semitic that's the one thing that's
the one line you can't cross he learned
the hard way he learned the hard way but
he that his goal was to get out of it
you're out Bubba you're out but now he
didn't he went a bad route to do it yeah
oh wow because he's out and now he can
get his own manufacturers half a billion
dollars I know that um can you imagine
Yeah that poor guy